Hillary Clinton says the investigation
will show in her words there is no case
here the newest Real Clear Politics
average of national polls shows her
leading Donald Trump by just over three
points now that is the closest margin in
a month Clinton's average lead was
nearly six points before the new FBI
probe was reported Nancy Cordes is in
White Plains New York covering the
Clinton campaign Nancy good morning good
morning set aside for the moment the
fact that you have the two major
candidates now accusing each other of
being in more trouble with the FBI than
they are beyond that the Clinton
campaign is arguing that it's unfair
that the FBI director has publicly
resurrected her investigation while
staying silent about Trump if they want
to look at some more emails of one of my
staffers by all means go ahead look at
them the Clinton campaign took its fight
with the FBI to the next level Monday
accusing director James Comey of playing
favorites I'm not confirming that we're
investigating people associated with mr.
Trump call me has refused to comment on
rumors that agents are investigating
Russian ties to some Trump associates
but he did alert lawmakers Friday about
new emails in the clinton case that may
or may not be significant that is
extremely troubling Annie ought to
answer for a Clinton's running mate Tim
Cain said Comey isn't following protocol
when it comes to Clinton I'm not raising
question as motors I'm just saying
there's a double standard mayotte
explaining the goal is to get the focus
back on Trump and off Clinton's
lingering legal troubles not to mention
more fallout from her campaigns hacked
emails interim DNC chair donna Brazile
has resigned from her contributor role
at CNN after WikiLeaks posted another
exchange in which she appeared to pass
the Clinton camp a debate question in
advance you see Donna Brazile was fired
from the network Trump said the campaign
should have come clean about the
question why did Hillary Clinton not
turn it in you know I have a son named
Baron and I want to tell you she is a
terrible example for my son and for the
children in this country that I can tell
you
the question was about lead in drinking
water came up at a primary debate in
Flint Michigan Brazil said in a
statement that she shared her thoughts
with all the Democratic campaigns the
Clinton campaign has had no comment door
all right Nancy thank you so much